[Musique]
suite au passage de birgitta les
sentiers de l'île ont été relativement
épargnés et leur réouverture ont été
assez rapide
sauf à l'exception du sentier reliant
bois court à grands bois ça où
d'importants dégâts ont été causés
les expertises du site réalisé par les
services de la direction régionale de
l'onef atteste de la dangerosité de
s'engager sur ce sentier donc le sentier
grand-bassam bois-court grand bassin est
fermé depuis 12 janvier pour cause des
bolides à bord suite à l'épisode épisode
pluvieux havas et ensuite vers guetta
nous sommes confrontés à trois éboulis
et une zone de fragilité du sentier l'a6
le tout avec un élément qui complique un
petit peu là la gestion du dossier
certaines canalisations localisation des
hirondelles les canalisations d'eau
potable qui est dessous donc qu' on ne
peut pas travailler sur le sentier sans
coordonnées avec la casud qui est le
gestionnaire de 7,7 canalisation qui est
actuellement coupée
en effet le diagnostic établi à
confirmer la présence de nombreux blocs
rocheux installe en amont du sentier la
disparition partielle et l'encombrement
de l'assise du sentier conscient des
enjeux socio économiques de ces
plaisions l'eau nf le département et ses
partenaires mettent actuellement tout en
oeuvre afin que cet accès soit rendue
dans les meilleurs délais aux habitants
de grand bassin et aux randonneurs
[Musique]